trên thần review Phó Hà Linh, ông Hộ Năm Tram Chuyệu làm từ diện.
Nhiều mong hộ tháng mùi một, Phó Hà Linh, cô gà nghe ăn được biết đến với biết sáng trên thần review,
đã đồng góc Năm Tram Chuyệu đồng vào quy tấm lòng vệt của đại chuyện Hình Vinh Nam,
thông qua chương trình trả tim cho em, đây là một chung những chương trình dân đạo,
khối chợi chạy mất bệnh tình bấm sinh thuộc xa đình có hoàn cảnh có khăn,
sức các em có kỳ hội được phó thuật và số phải máy.
Phó Hà Linh không còn là cải tên xa là với người dụ mặt xa hội tại Việt Nam,
sinh ra tại giãn cô nổi tiếng với những bài đệnh sạm sản phẩm chức kép và chúng thực,
chờ thành đường tức trong cộng đồng nguyết thư dùng, với phong cách đình giá thành thánh và có chắc nhận,
suại người nguyết video của Hà Linh đã khiến cô chờ thành một trong những review ở Hà Nau,
với hàng triệu người theo dõi trên tất nền tạm chức tính, trước đó,
lưỡi tích tất cơ cơ cũng đậu hộ hàng chăm chựa đồng cho đồng bảo các tình phía bác,
bịt tế thạch sò bảo lúc, và những đường xe kênh người của cộng đồng mặt.